[Musique]
superman
je vous explique ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on est un con et mylène et
on attend d'avoir de change actuel pour
parler de xiaomi là je viens de
récupérer matt piol 227
on va parler de schumi on va reparler de
tous les produits écosystèmes d'europe
de shiro me on va parler de l'ami
vendons pas reparler de choses je
cherche ma piaule 226 oies au la vache
vous avez vu la taille de la pioche oh
la vache
aa ont soupesé gueule que tu arrives là
regardez moi ça regarde et on a ça le
pieux et nobles le petit canapé cosy
l'espace pour bosser j'arrive gtv qui a
lui même
nava y'a pas à dire ça quand même mais
bon les voyages de presse un bon alors
regardez là c'est la salle de bain j'ai
pas encore poser mon sac à dos tellement
j'arrive à cette page
le kif dommage que je parle demain matin
4 heures du match pour pouvoir profiter
je pense que je vais pas dormir donc
aujourd'hui on parle de xiaomi et
franchement
[Musique]
on va parler de l'ami band 3 appareils
monde connecté on va parler de
l'écosystème shiomi
on va pas les trucs hyper cool mais je
voulais vous parler d'autre chose juste
avant j'ai reçu un objet qu'elle a
plutôt cool qui sert quand on bosse je
voulais montrer hier cet objet de cet
argus c'est un travel doc qui vous
permet de connecter tout ce que vous
voulez là dessus et je pense que ça peut
vous sauver la vie je vous montre ça
parce que j'en profite d'être en
déplacement pour vraiment illustré ça
vous allez pouvoir brancher tous vos
périphériques dessus directement sur
votre bécane vous le brancher en usb
type c sur votre ordinateur c'est un
espèce de couteau suisse du branchement
vous avez de la prise vga du hdmi de la
prise ethernet de l'usb de l'usb type
ses fins il ya pas mal de choses et vous
pouvez brancher tous directement ici en
usb type c il est compatible pour pc et
pour mac c'est vraiment l'outil idéal
notamment pour brancher de la vidéo si
vous avez un petit videoprojecteur si
vous avez un moniteur pour être branché
là dessus et ça peut vraiment être très
pratique d'une solution qui est vraiment
hyper pratique pour les nomades
je pense notamment aux professionnels
qui veulent vraiment pas s'endetter et
qui veulent un outil extrêmement simple
pour pouvoir aller n'importe où brancher
n'importe quoi de façon très facile et
ça je trouve ça vraiment cool s'il vous
intéresse vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description
[Musique]
ça commence dans combien de temps la
coff des médias leur nez
rick l on est en avance de cinq minutes
ça commençait là on est presque à leur
pouvoir commencer
[Musique]
on s'en remet à peine de la conf de
xiaomi où on a effectivement vu deux
produits majeurs qui ont été lancés
selmi band 3 qui succède au 1022 mais
pendant un tarif complètement 29,99
et puis un projecteur laser avec un
processeur intérieur fait pas mal de
choses hélas ce qui est super
intéressant je voulais acheter un petit
coup d'oeil c'est vraiment pour parler
de l'écosystème complet chili par
exemple on a ici la fameuse contre les
électrons
deux smartphones de la maison connectée
la brosse à dents électrique y côtoie
déjà parlé on a aussi par ici là le
fameux projecteur laser qui est juste là
derrière là vous allez pouvoir vous
déplacer près vous avez aussi des petits
robots pour se marrer là vous avez des
montres connectés hamas vite et on a
testé déjà une montre collectés dans la
cité a pas très longtemps
on en reparlera aussi probablement
prochainement là vous avez la macif ps
est là la fameuse me band 3 qui se
trouve juste ici mais ça on va
développer d'ici quelques temps il ya
aussi des solutions qui sont hyper
intéressante pour la maison c'est
vraiment du smart home c'est à dire que
vous avez un kit complet de prise
connectés de lumière connectés de wifi
là vous avez typiquement un wireless
which vous avez des capteurs d'intrusion
on va reconnaître ici quand quelqu'un va
venir
arrivé chez vous va ouvrir la porte
quand tu es tout un système d'allah
c'est vraiment intéressant ces solutions
de smart home parce que ça montre
vraiment comment va se positionner le
marché comme on va développer votre
maison connectée pour vous apporter plus
de solutions plus de sécurité et vous
faciliter la vie et vous avez aussi avec
bien évidemment pour la sécurité la
surveillance des caméras à 360 degrés là
vous avez là me home security caméra 360
degrés vision infrarouge de nuit et 720p
de réseau sans fin avril ça c'est tous
des solutions très complète pour le
smart home et là dessus il va aussi y
avoir des nouveautés made in show mais
d'ici quelques temps voyez là vous allez
typiquement le pack complet qu'on voit
là c'est vraiment des choses
intéressante on continue avec la maison
est la plus avec la santé connectés on a
ici la brosse à dents chez au mieux on
l'a déjà testé il ya pas longtemps
là on n'est plus dans
le fit pour vous peser le pèse personne
connectée de chironi il ya aussi des
écouteurs pas mal de choses un vrai
écosystème complet 12h10
[Musique]
c'est au final c'est vraiment super
intéressant parce que ça permet de
montrer tout le potentiel tout là la
diversification cash a omis vis-à-vis de
ses produits après vous avez une
application pour le faire tourner c'est
vraiment une solution à 360° et c'est
vraiment là dessus qui est super fort
shiomi c est capable de vous captez sur
un smartphone pour nous emmener ensuite
sur votre télé pour vous emmener ensuite
quand vos déplacements avec votre
trottinette électrique pour ensuite être
présent chez vous pour la sécurité pour
ouvrir vos pores vos fenêtres pour des
théories qu'il ya besoin avec une
politique tarifaire qui est extrêmement
basse ils ont fait un choix de 5% de
marge pour avoir une politique tarifaire
extrêmement agressive l'annoncé la plus
importante aujourd'hui ça reste quand
même l'ami band 3 qui est juste là et
qu'on va tester d'ici quelques jours on
voit beaucoup pour en parler parce qu'on
va s'intéresser vraiment au monde
connecté vous allez voir c'est vraiment
une problématique super intéressantes à
faire du sport on a retrouvé un petit
peu ensemble
il faut savoir que là dessus vous avez
un écran oled de 0,78 pouces qui est
quand même 53% plus large que la version
précédente
elle fait 20 grammes tout le bracelet
est en silicone elle est résistante à
l'eau jusqu'à 50 mais vous pouvez aller
à la piscine vous pouvez faire du sort
vous pouvez vous l'avez avec sans aucun
problème vous avez un capteur de rythme
cardiaque plus de vingt jours
d'autonomie avec une batterie de 110
millions terreur faut dire que là-dessus
l'écran va pas consommer normes
donc franchement vous avez de quoi voir
rien vous avez un tracking d'activité
enfin tout ce qu'on peut retrouver un
petit peu classiquement sur des mondes
connectés et tout ça vous de piloter
depuis l'application misfits et vous
pourrez retrouver au tarif de 29 euros
99 à partir du 7 septembre
je vous ai mis bien évidemment un lien
dans la description vous invite à aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil et autres
annonces qui souffre aujourd'hui c'est
le mit laser projecteurs alors c'est moi
mon domaine
la projection la salle comme ça plutôt
cool parce que ça donne un écran de 150
pouces sont pas projetés l'intérêt est
vraiment de ce projecteur ce que vous
allez poser à 70 cm ça vous fait un
écran énorme 250 pousse alors à
l'intérieur vous avez un truc super cool
vous avez un capteur infrarouge
j'avais un refroidissement liquide vous
avez un processeur qui va vraiment
calculé optimisé l'image que vous avez
également android tv netflix que tu déjà
pas mal de choses à la télé tout ce que
vous voulez et entourent où vous avez 25
mille heures de visionnage de giga de
ram 64 giga de stockage une télécommande
qui est compatible google à 6 ans et un
tarif de 1899 euros
bon là maintenant ils veulent que leurs
devoirs un coup parce qu'ici là tout le
monde est en train de boire un coup seul
en train de filmer de travailler voilà
des nervis d'à côté de moi c'est même
pas d'incarner profiter c'est d'une
tristesse absolue aux quelques infos à
vous donner j'ai discuté avec des
membres de l'équipe de chine au mileu
1008 explorer edition va arriver d'ici
très peu de temps en france quand il
aura pas un dos aussi transparent que ce
qu'on a pu voir lors de la présentation
il aura un dos transparent mais il sera
pas aussi transparent avec tous les
composants
ça reste néanmoins un produit qui entre
sans papiers super cool
autre point intéressant chez eux où ils
vont vers d'autres store en france et ça
on le verra un peu plus tard ils vont
également arrivée en angleterre d'ici
très peu de temps
benelux pareil dit si loin devant en
allemagne dix monuments et là ils sont
en train de préparer leur arrivée un peu
plus tard aux états unis commence à
bosser dessus soit plus compliqué pour
l'entreprise chinoise d'arriver
directement aux autres infos concernant
le mx3 en tout cas le successeur de wii
knee de s on sait qu'il y aura un
nouveau modèle mon m'a pas du tout
confirmé le nom ministre oreilles parce
qu'après pas non plus autre chose ça
sera une mise à jour de l'appareil ne
sera pas un nouvel appareil avec des
fonctions était complètement dingue donc
je pense que là dessus il va falloir
s'attendre à voir des choses
complètement révolutionnaire votre info
qui concerne pas shiomi qui concerne au
nord vous m'avez posé la question
étaient très nombreux à poser la
question concernant une arrivée en
france due au nord notes 10 je vais vous
décevoir le note 10 n'arrivera pas en
france ce plan parce que le marché des
grands écrans un peu fable est n'est pas
mûr et ne marche pas en france marche
très bien en asie mais pas en france
donc pas de honore notre dit si vous le
voulez il va falloir la porte et me vole
un peu pour ces quelques infos choper
chaudement directement tac auprès des
équipes de chiens au mit on va continuer
à en parler parce que je vous dis va y
avoir le lancement de ce nouveau produit
mal m'en le mois prochain je sais pas où
ça va se passer je sais pas comment ça
va se passer
on en reparlera donc une fois de plus je
vous invite à vous abonner
elle est épaulée
[Applaudissements]
nous
à mantoue les mots-clés rincon intrigue
hockey dubaï
sup à main
ça la technique c'est quoi ouais les
phénix et de donner de grands coups de
vent en poupe
je pense que je me casse le poignet
la gueule avant de poursuivre mon gars
le juge a dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ricola a c'est super cool comme génial
qui trottinait ce qu'il faut que tu
testes c'est le truc à deux pieds au
tripode le rsa même message mais oui moi
j'ai juste à tomber c'est la première
fois opté savent pas sûr
il pleut pas il est là le sou milan
c'est triste enfin on s'est dit on va
venir à milan ça va être génial en
profiter du soleil plein air seront n'a
pas dit on va profiter du soleil on a
dit on va travailler mon bon monsieur
on a dit on va travailler là bas on est
venu à milan pour travailler mamelles ça
fait de la trottinette à kampala
tranquillement pris entre-temps peu trop
du soleil ces coûts le soleil une
chanson une semaine le lundi au soleil
il faut faire la corée du nord la corée
la corée
[Rires]
[Musique]